[Music]
good morning
today we are talking about romance
languages
any news you want to share there's still
no signs of first contact
the objects measure at least 1500 feet
tall
dr banks i'm colonel gt webber i have
something i need you to translate for me
[Applause]
is that everyone is able to process
experiences like this
when's the last time you did something
stressful does now count
we need answers as soon as possible what
do they want
where are they from
[Music]
how many we're one of 12. we're a world
with no single leader
it's impossible to deal with just one of
us we need to go back in
well i guess i don't need to tell you
you're putting yourself at risk
that's a proper introduction to
everything that happens it comes down to
the two of us
i know what it is what does this say
offer weapon
i don't need an interpreter to know what
this means we don't know if they
understand the difference between
a weapon and a tool china just
threatened to destroy their shells
whatever they do france and korea will
follow we could be facing global war
we need to talk to the other and work
together for once
we have 15 hours before this all goes to
hell
i know why they're here what the hell is
she doing
do trust me
[Music]
come on peter that's your suit
it's heartening to see so many strange
new faces here today
i know my mom would be very touched and
probably a little suspicious
my mother was a very secretive and
private woman
it's grandma you know you were her
favorite right
even when you're a little baby she
wouldn't let me feed you because she
needed to feed you
she was a very difficult woman which
maybe explains me
i recognize you from your mother what
sometimes i swear i can feel them in the
room
she isn't gone
she had private rituals private friends
who's gonna take care of me you don't
think i'm gonna take care of you
but when you die
wasn't all together there
at the end
mom i don't like this dad i don't like
this what's happening
don't you ever raise your voice
i just don't want to put any more stress
on my family
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's one thing you should know about
me i specialize in a very specific type
of security
subconscious security you're talking
about dreams
[Music]
mr carl has a job offer he would like to
discuss with you
what kind of work placement
not exactly we create the world of the
dream
we bring the subject into that dream and
they fill it with their secrets
then you break in and steal it well it's
not strictly speaking leaving
it's called inception
i think i found a way home and this
last job that's how i get there
dreams feel real while we're in them
it's only when we wake up that we
realize something was actually strange
is your responsibility we are not
prepared for this
[Music]
dream's collapsing
i have it under control
i'd like to see out of control
you mustn't be afraid to dream a little
bigger darling
nick dunn you're probably the most hated
man
in america right now did you kill your
wife nick
everyone told us and told us marriage is
hard work not for me and nick
as you all know my wife amy elliott time
disappeared three days ago i had nothing
to do
with the disappearance of my wife i have
nothing to hide sammy got friends we can
talk to
no not really you don't know if she has
friends you don't know what she does all
day and you don't know your wife's blood
type
just being a good guy so everybody can
see him being a good guy well you really
don't like him do you all i'm trying to
do
is be nice to the people who are
volunteering to help find amy
i will practice believing my husband
loves me
but i could be wrong have you ever seen
that guy in the glasses before amy is
the kind of girl who attracts admirers
whoever took her is bound to bring her
back i'm hoping you can tell me what
this means
you want to solve amy's treasure hunt
seen this girl around here yeah
i remember her i know you i saw you at
the volunteer center
i wanted to help what she wanted she
wanted a gun we are
all scared but we are all here now i
feel like something to be jettisoned if
necessary
i feel like i could disappear the
hallmark of a sociopath
is a lack of empathy and you lost a lot
of blood in there and then somebody
mopped it up why they mop up the blood
if they're trying to stage a crime scene
whatever they found i think it's safe to
assume that it's very bad
i finally realized i am frightened of my
own husband i will join you as if you're
doing a deposition
what to say what not to say a trained
monkey monkey who doesn't get lethal
injections
she's going to eat you alive you
assaulted her it's not good enough for
you i hit her it's not even close
absolutely not i never touched her we
now believe nick is involved in the
disappearance of our daughter without a
body without a murder weapon
their only hope is a confession i don't
know anything yet you need to tell me
how was your marriage named are you
asking me if i killed my wife man of my
dreams
this man of mine may kill me what about
my son nick this man may kill me
in her own words this man may truly
[Music]
kill me you ever hear the expression the
simplest answer is often the correct one
actually i've never found that to be
true
[Music]
harlan started out with a rusty smith
corona and built himself into one of the
best-selling mystery writers of all time
30 languages over 80 million copies sold
you guys fans i mean i don't do much
fiction reading myself
big fan i'm a big fan who is that guy
mr blanc is a private investigator of
great renown i read a tweet about a new
yorker article about you
you're famous with nine of his demise
the family had gathered to celebrate
your father's 85th birthday
and your son ransom did he attend as
well yes but he left early i think linda
was upset
walt would get a little irish courage in
him he'd get into it with harlan
what richard said what
are you baiting me detective attempting
to be thorough so we can figure out the
matter of death you mean if someone
killed him
you think one of us one of his family
mr blanc i just buried my father who
committed suicide why are you here
i suspect foul play i have eliminated no
suffering
harlem was cleaning house everyone
the family has possible motives was
hauling planning on cutting off johnny
did he plan to file walter this is
richard having an affair
that's some heavy-duty conjecture funny
ransom you skipped the funeral but
you're early for the will reading
up your ass very nice
[Music]
i gotta do this more often the family is
truly desperate
when people get desperate the knives
come out
this is a twisted web
and we are not finished untangling it
not yet
i keep waiting for the big reveal
all of them lied to me there is
one guilty party behind it all
you know something spill it
oh my god tell me what happened to my
grandfather
i think you have something you want to
tell me
[Music]
when i was your age they would say you
could become cops
or criminals what i'm saying is this
when you're facing a loaded gun
what's the difference this is not the
regular please
this is the state please we are an elite
unit this is who we're after
frank costello you won't be paid as a
regular cop but there's a bonus involved
so what do i do
[Music]
you will not ever know the identity of
undercover people you have anyone in
with costello presently maybe do you
know who i am
maybe not i'm gonna have my associate
search you
[Music]
that was quick you think he's dead
already get your hands on
me i think we could work somehow
we are all convinced that customer has
at least one mole inside the special
investigations unit
there are parts of my job i can't talk
to you about man you
are trouble you don't know the half of
it
you better get organized quick hey last
time i checked i tipped you off and
you're not in jail
getting the feeling we got a cop in my
crew
so the ladies gonna find out who i am
he's gonna kill me
i can get the wrap you just gotta let me
do it my way
if you don't it won't be me who pays for
there is a it from the inside it's real
man smoking out
you're lying to me there are things you
don't want to know about
[Music]
what are you waiting for honestly i mean
you wanted to chop me up and feed me the
poor
is that what you guys want
[Music]
how's your brother she's on her way out
y'all are act accordingly
you don't go to the movies do you i
don't
i don't go out that much
is there a reason why you're asking me
this you know maybe you had a
recommendation
[Music]
anthony clare three 3650
rathburn road hello uh good afternoon
hey um no i'm calling to speak today i'm
calling from
i'm sorry i think there's been a
misunderstanding okay
i'll call back later
[Music]
who was on the phone the same guy who
called before
same guy are you lying to me
[Music]
[Music]
you are my only son i am your only
mother
he looks exactly like you what's
happening
i don't really don't know what you're
talking about
[Music]
why'd you come looking for me i needed
to know i have some questions for you
who are you what's wrong you're crazy
i'm crazy
whoa mom dad you gotta come see what i
was so bad
you just got it come come on whoa
having spoken the doomsayer departs
[Music]
why don't you get billy dress i'll take
a minute down with him hit the store
work it's all bought out how do you
folks hold up in the storm
big insurance day sorry to hear that
what's going on
it's death
[Music]
something in the mist shut the doors
shut the door
the only way we're going to help
ourselves is to seek rescue
tie this around your waist before let us
know you got at least three hundred feet
there's nothing out there nothing in the
midst what if you're wrong
then i guess
it is time to take sides read the good
book it calls
for blood
guys i hear something are those
bugs not like any i've ever seen the
entire front of the store is playing
glass were you guys messing with up
there
i thought there were other dimensions
they wanted to try and make a window
well maybe your window turned out to be
a door
who she's gonna sacrifice to make it all
better we want the boy board
what are you gonna do with it i'm gonna
give it something socially responsible
to do
can't we just let it go this thing needs
to learn how to adapt
all right game let's mask up like the
rest of us
[Music]
this world's a treasure there's been
times to leave for a while now
your daughter's generation will be the
last to survive on earth
you're the best pilot we ever had get
out there
and save the world everybody ready to
say goodbye to our
solar system to our galaxy
here we go
we're here want to get down fast don't
we
actually we want to get there in one
piece hang on
we have a mission our mission does not
work if the people on earth are dead by
the time we pull it off
[Music]
we got this far farther than any human
in history well not far enough
the waves
you are yes you are
you might have to decide between seeing
your children again
and the future of the human race we'll
find a way
that we always have
[Music]
you